now we have the next level of how uh
insane this gets confirmation from axios
google suspends parlor from app store
after deadly capital violence
this is not gonna stop it it's it's a
simple apk download
okay google takes it out of the play
store and then they put it up on their
website
so when you open your phone and you go
to parlor.com eventually at some point i
assume it'll say download the apk you'll
click it boom you got it what does
removing it from the play store do
it slows things down significantly i
mean we were suspended from
google play and app store for like six
months yeah so you go to mines.com
mobile and get the mobile app now you
can get the apk or you get us in the app
stores but like
you know that hurt us and it it will
hurt parlor and you know that it's
and the thing is that it's become too
polarized it's like
the left you know twitter the left-wing
social network parlor the right-wing
social network it's like
it it need we need from a high level at
the companies to be
having serious conversations live
streaming
and saying how are we going to bring
this community together how are we going
to deal with these people
or nationalize social media or a
globalized one
one that follows the us constitution
that we create i mean it will be
globalized it can be anybody in the
world we can use it
and it will follow the us constitution
yes i don't think they would ever and
an app we need a website social network
that does it and we need
um an isp that follows the us
constitution that's not a private
company
so let me read a little bit of this they
say quote in order to protect user
safety on google play our long-standing
policies require that apps displaying
user-generated content have moderation
policies
and enforcement that removes egregious
content like posts that incite violence
jose castaneda a google spokesperson
said
in light of this ongoing and urgent
public safety threat
we are suspending the apps listing from
the play store until it addresses these
issues
what does that mean uh you're not
allowed to incite violence on parlor
they'll ban you for it no joke in fact
parlor's got very strict rules
my understanding is that they they
operate on what's called like a
broadcast standard meaning
you actually can't like you can't say
certain things that are free speech
and that's and that's the way they run
their platform i mean it's it's a gab
2.0
situation basically and and the problem
you know
free speech policies every network
should have but like the fact that there
there's you know there are privacy
issues and transparency issues with
parlor
i'm just gonna you know be upfront about
that like their code is not open source
you can't see their algorithms
if you're listening guys open source
your code like
networks have to be open source
otherwise it's not viable in the long
term
i think uh the i don't know if the
fetaverse is the answer we've talked
about it before
but some kind of decentralized federated
social network
the way it would work it's very simple
is how the photoverse works is that
you don't have to use parlor you would
use just
you know fetiverse apps a regular old
app you download and then you
you sign in to your server or their
server or whatever server and it
connects all the different companies
into one social media system yeah the
fetiverse is great
it's the activity pub protocol which
mastodon uses
which many sites are integrating
there's another another one polaroma
we're working on activity pub
integration
been it's taken way too long for us to
do it but it's a great process
the problem the problem with it though
is that when you subscribe to someone on
another node
you the comment threads don't work right
it's just like it's so it's sort of
messy it's still good and it's a step in
the right direction but it's not truly
decentralized social media
because you know the admins can still
ban the whole
you know they can cut off like if there
was a networked you know gab
connected to mines you know one platform
could cut off the other platform
right yeah well the idea is is
preliminary i suppose but how do we get
to the point where if i choose to follow
the president for his updates
no one can take that away ever i think
they call it internet 2.0 the tron
network was working on something like
that well that's what we integrated with
with the perma web with the r-weave
blockchain basically
you have the option when you post to
post to the perma
we you know obviously you don't want
every post to be permanent but the
reality is that we're moving into a
blockchain
decentralized world and that that is a
little bit scary
but ethereum is going to skyrocket
ethereum yeah i just bought something
32 exposure but uh you you bring up a
blockchain
i think what a lot of people need to
realize is that the a lot of these
networks they use crypto they're built
off of the ethereum
cryptocurrency and there are some other
amazing decentralized social networks
like
scuttlebutt is fully decentralized it's
sort of like techy and
and tough to use but it's it is fully
decentralized so it's on your machine
everything
um yeah so regarding the r-weave network
if you were to post something
um on the are we blockchain and then you
owned that post and it was there forever
could it then generate crypto tokens for
every view that it accrued
that's not how their system works but
i mean theoretically you could build
whatever you want i remember at burning
man some people
started to do peer-to-peer uh
bluetooth communications um yeah uh
i was i was on a a cruise and they told
everyone when you come on to download
this app i thought it was called
but you turn on bluetooth and then this
is the craziest thing
you could walk past one person and all
the data is being transmitted from like
my app to their app and then when they
walk past another person it bounces to
like five more people
and then created this mesh internet
where if i was standing 10 feet from you
you were 10 feet from me and ian was 10
feet from you know you know bob smith
and then bob smith sent a message it
would relay through everyone to me yeah
local networks that's amazing that's
really important for countries that
don't have serious infrastructure yeah
well also in the united kingdom when
rock and roll
was banned what they started to do is
literal pirate ships they had
ships that would broadcast uh rock and
roll
oh i saw that movie and yeah yeah radio
yeah radio
there's you know there's whole movies
about this you know censorship
throughout history
is something that is more common than
not than uncommon
so we have to understand uh you know
this is a
going towards a trend that that i don't
want to be on well so here's what's
going to happen
the the left controls the cultural
institutions so a political coup in my
opinion is totally meaningless
it is what we're seeing right now is
actually i'll step back as they say
politics downstream from culture
by getting rid of all of the voices that
can you know
propagate certain ideas those ideas used
to exist
that's it they're gone they've been
slowly and methodically removing
certain ideas and certain people from
these platforms and they've been doing
it for a very long time and i remember
they were doing it to individuals that i
didn't like
i didn't agree with i didn't identify
with i was like yeah i don't like these
guys
too but but i don't think their voice
should be censored and i've been saying
that consistently from the very
beginning
but they used our own fears our own
emotions against us
to justify it slowly and surely and now
we're here today i think the argument is
it can't be stopped
like it is downstream from culture and
the technology so we need a
technological revolution that will
prevent
anyone from being able to do that it is
happening but that's why it's crazy
bitcoin's hitting all-time highs today
i mean that is the decentralized
infrastructure for
the new system yeah it's incredible well
what is it what does a bitcoin get you
in terms of that system though
like bitcoin can't do you can do things
on top of bitcoin as well there are
projects that are trying to build
layer two solutions on top of different
blockchains this is the thing it's an
encryption peer-to-peer
technology and it's it's something new
like the printing press
so when the printing press came out
everyone in the beginning was like oh
this is nothing this is an old machine
this is not going to do anything but but
it revolutionized
the way people gathered information
bitcoin is revolutionizing the way
people
transact and just like the internet
double-edged sword
could go either way could go towards the
total venezuelan russian cryptocurrency
track tracing database system
or it could go towards a
decentralization liberty sovereignty
freedom
uh technology that helps people be
individuals helps people be secure and
most
most importantly helps people be private
let me tell you about the
radicalization of the left in this
country in 2016 i did an interview with
oliver darcy
when he was working at business insider
he's now at cnn on reliable sources
the interview was because i tweeted out
defense
of alt-right white nationalists who were
being removed from twitter
now these people weren't saying you know
inciting violence
these were people who were posting nasty
opinions i didn't like
these are people who don't like me at
all because of who my my because of my
family's
you know regional heritage i'll put it
that way and so oliver darcy asked me
like what are you what are your thoughts
on i said it's a slippery slope
you start removing people because you
like these ideas then eventually they're
banning the left
that was oliver darcy recently for the
past day or so
he advocated for cable providers to ban
fox news oan and newsmax because they
spread lies
talk about a dramatic change from where
he was
only four or so years ago when he was
interviewing me
because he thought it was newsworthy i
said we must have free speech even for
those we don't like
i am still standing here on the same
hill saying we must have free speech for
those we don't like otherwise you create
conflict
and he now has gone so far that not only
is he advocating for the removal of
entire cable channels
he's contacting a t and verizon and
comcast
and saying will you remove them you're
responsible etc you're allowed to spread
lies in the united states
well protected again that's still
absolutely unhinged
dangerous behavior that corporations who
want more power
with little fleeing individuals coming
them coming to them saying please take
away all my rights take away everything
take away the most important right of
what my ears could listen to
of course they're going to be like yes
give it to me i'll be your overlord
daddy
come on here and again we've seen this
coming for a long time one of the major
criticisms against donald trump within
the last few years
is that he's not making a stand against
free speech he's not making a stand
against the first amendment
many of his critics what do you mean a
stand against do you mean that standing
up for
standing up for the first amendment
standing up for free speech
and and it's interesting to see laura
loomer tweet this out
today she said according to a telegram
post at least
trump can still order a sandwich on uber
eats though
for now i can't say the same sadly
so again uh this has been happening to a
lot of his core supporters
we you know again and you know you know
you know you know the interesting
laura loomer [ __ ] was was beyond the
canary in the coal mine i mean this was
like
someone yelling the the coal mine is
full of carbon monoxide get out now
and the republicans weren't smart enough
to to push through legislation while
they had the chance so did loomer get
taken off the stripe or the uh the
this was it the swift payment system she
got banned from the global payments
i
when did you ever hear anything like
that no why can't she use money who babe
what do you mean what are you talking
about laura loomer
uber eats she's super amazing you can't
get banned from not her finances
no she was she was banned i believe from
those platforms as well but not swift
that is nothing
are you sure you can't be put on a black
list of swift you probably probably i
mean mastercard reached out to patreon
over
uh this guy what was his name uh robert
spencer i think so yeah he yeah
spencer yeah uh what it was the wrong
spencer it wasn't richard spencer
no robert robertson yes and and when you
mean the wrong spencer he was the person
they were targeting on purpose
he writes about jesus oh that's right
that's right he writes about radical
islam
and mastercard got angry and said to
patreon remove him otherwise we'll cut
off services
i think mastercard was forced to do that
by swift i could be wrong about that
i mean this is actually a historic day
yeah i think we actually have to zoom
out and
let it sink in for a second this is the
corporate
takeover of i mean the corporate this
proves corporations have more power
than the government that's right
corporations have just removed the
speech of the sitting u.s president
yep michael michael tracy has a comment
here that i think is really timely he
says
quote corporate left liberals are
desperate
for revenge they will use all powers at
their disposal
public and private to neutralize their
purported
insurrectionist enemies and they
absolutely do not care one bit
what civil liberties are destroyed in
the process
divisive i don't want to say this is
left and right but why
speeding is yes it is it's not though
it's
way more than two sides it's it's a
bunch of people with a bunch of
different ideas
but it is very frustrating that trump
didn't facilitate
a cross-spectrum conversation more
directly like he had the opportunity
yeah and it seems like he really did not
bring the people bill
you and i were in the white house at the
social media event yeah you're the ceo
of a company he could be using
and someone said will you just use
another platform he says which one
which one i don't know donald trump and
joe biden and
all the progressives both sides we have
to constantly be disclaiming
that we need both sides yes there's no
network without you consider using minds
tech for a government
program that we could yeah they can use
it hey call me up government
yeah i mean make your own yeah social
network with the mind software that
could integrate with
mind the minds node is a proof of
absolutely
i mean the government just just um okay
banks running bitcoin and ethereum nodes
which is a very big deal what we're
seeing unfortunately is
tribalist divide there's not just two
factions
there's hundreds and probably thousands
but there
are two overarching parent factions of
these
these overarching parent factions we
just typically refer to them as left and
right but that means very little
for instance how is it that tim poole
who's economically left
and even socially left is considered
right-wing
because i believe in freedom free speech
liberty principles
integrity etc that is not something that
exists
for the most part among the left what
the left believes in is for one
what did we see from cuomo on cnn during
the riots he said who says protesters
have to have to be peaceful right and
then
ramen guy comes out and says it's right
there in the first amendment mr comey's
got to look it up
then then you get jake tapper and cnn
saying oh i can't believe what they're
doing
when the riots happened i said those
riots are bad when the riots the
capitals
happened i said those riots are bad
there is principle
and i'm not saying everybody on the
right has it i'm saying
it's not something typically of the left
it is a tendency
i can't take the right and the left
stuff dude the chinese the chinese used
the rightists this was the com mao's
communist takeover was against the
rightists they focused on dividing
people into these camps and then
targeted
use them against each other but what you
need to understand is the divide is a
real thing well not made
up by someone
millions of different concepts at once
and to
just think that we're in different camps
of of types is crazy
conservatives right now calling for the
removal of their political opponents
from major players it's not a
conservative
move it's a very liberal move exactly
and it's only coming from what we
colloquially refer to as
the right there are some on the left
liberals and progressives people like
glenn greenwald but now they call him
alt-right and matt taibi and michael
tracy who does i don't
th there's there's there are two tribes
you can call them tribes a and b
one or two it doesn't matter where where
are these two they're the overarching
parents to numerous
other tribes you have to use words ian
yeah i will and is it because there's
democrat and republican two power
parties so we say then there's left and
there's right
two it's a reference to the french
revolution to those who set on the left
and those who set on the right yes and
those on the right were
you know moderates and those on the left
were radicals who wanted revolution i
think it's so dangerous to get into that
mind well using more specific
language is actually i'm not going to
sit here and say the socialists
the anarchists the communists the
tankers
no blame their group for what they did
if someone does something they're
responsible for that
it is a tendency among all of the
factions
on both sides to hold certain ideals and
principles
they don't completely agree with each
other left fights themselves all the
time
on the right you have people who are
awful
and white nationalists who would defend
donald trump and the left doesn't
but that is not the over overwhelmingly
that's not overwhelmingly the majority
or even a large portion of what the
right represents in fact
the alt-right and the white nationalists
actually agree with the left and a ton
of left-wing policy issues the point is
when it comes to the cultural debate
there are two apparent factions fine we
won't say left and right we'll say one
and two
you're not one or two dude i know yeah
right there's more than
one and two or three but pragmatically
ian you have to use words in order to
have a conversation
it's like saying but are you gonna vote
republican or democrat this time well
that yeah absolutely
you should be talking about all the
options thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you